welcome to this video we match for this
video channel for this viewer challenge
against Kabul y'all Krieger this is a
German name of the city German flag and
this translate to the cotta warrior I
needed to look that up
Carbon yo is a fish and it's the cut-in
in English I have the only night age 5
mm-hmm yeah this is an interesting line
okay let's see me move this night age
too but there have been some recent so
recent games with that that I didn't
really like yeah let's see what happens
this tree is really just yeah actually
black should not be able to play this he
played it anyway due to Knight takes e5
but maybe okay right if five what is the
idea of night night g3 maybe Knight e5
Knight takes g3 fg3
Bishop e5 hmm not the same okay let's
let's get ahead ah Queen yet oh I forgot
about that news
I immediately saw it after playing
yeah that's really not necessary
especially because 95 is also simply
better for Ward 5 is just a balance but
not due to this
okay just a piece there just a piece
okay
yeah simply Knight f6 and I'm playing
with the piece down yeah well it's just
just dead let's see maybe he tries to
play it I can they can even take yeah he
could have even taken it would have been
even even easier okay
Knight Queen Queen to h4 is also also
possible okay
yeah of course it's lost in any case hmm
yeah maybe maybe try that then g5 rook
h1 I know in order to to muddy the
waters should keep the Queen song but my
king is really if it really were seer
can cannot even castle quickly you know
g5 he also simply has some simply has
some Bishop f5 yeah simply blundered the
piece a 95 yeah and it's always funny if
you do this really idiotic blunders you
instantly once you play it you see it
you know I immediately saw that not
Queen yet is coming after tagging I
played it really quickly
Bishop d4 was was even easier now age
six is hanging really
it's not a problem yet but Bishop D for
earlier was much easier
Bishop's III it's the idea it stopped
really nothing can play everything
bookie aid you can even just give away
the exchange is are still excellent for
when this covers fe2 any for Java this
is not so so much of a problem I mean
compared to the other problems that I
have
I can take a bishop see form check sure
that lets convincing still winning
probably but it feels like I have some
come to play at least with f6 may be
coming hmm it's still it's still a bit
tricky you're threatening mate now check
check and g5 made at the end check yeah
this does not check me just does not
help yeah well I'm just yeah more than
lucky then the really the easiest
easiest was to was to just play play
Bishop II phone here check check and
then I probably would have resigned
because there's absolutely no not the
slightest idea and everything one but
you know and another easy spot is this
here attacking d5 with check so that the
problem is I cannot take on edge six
because of Bishop t5 check and if he
takes it I mean I'm fostering through
from the edge file and then there's
absolutely zero cheating chances him
swindling chancing cheating it's really
not the right word cheating its nowadays
always associated with computer chess no
I mean like
trying fishing fishing in muddy waters
and to try to irritate them and this
there's nothing here yeah yeah Knight
takes e5 what a lemon that really
relieved your take what I need to do is
is my g5 I mean this is a normal move
and then you should be too intending 96
this is the the positional continuation
that I think should be quite okay for
white and maybe maybe somewhat better
not not much but we nee 8 yeah that no
words alright thanks for watching